afternoon
everyone thank thank you councelor Baker
thank you to think I was on my own
there so um before we start the meeting
as outlined on the agenda I'm going to
uh ask Mrs Sternberg to once again just
talk to us about the situation of
microphones over you please Mrs
Sternberg thank you chair um hopefully
for the last time this is the
arrangements for the council meeting
today with the microphones we've engaged
again engaged Tim Nightingale a sound
engineer to set up the arrangements and
Supply the mics to work well so that
everyone can hear the mics must be used
properly the streaming is also very
dependent on the proper use of the mics
there are fixed mics for the front row
and some others everyone else will be
using a radio mic if using the fixed
mics you will need to indicate to Tim
that you wish to speak if you're using a
radio mic you will need to indicate your
desire to speak and one of the
governance team will provide a mic in
both cases please speak directly into
the mics they are designed for the
speaker to be very close and do not work
if the speaker is at a distance from the
mic or not speaking into it the chair
request that you do not stand when
speaking so that you can get as close to
the mics as possible Tim will switch off
the mic when you finished speaking an
extra one please don't russle your
papers near someone who is speaking the
mic can pick this up as well votes will
be taken by a roll call in order to
obtain accurate figures for against and
abstaining the way each member votes
when a roll call is used will not be
recorded in the minutes unless a
recorded vote has been asked for thank
you
chair thank you so item one apologies
for absence we have apologies already
conveyed from councilors
antcliffe
Burkin Durant and
Tate are there any other
apologies Council Barker yeah uh Nikki
moley thank you Council
Dale
read any
others
now item two Declarations of Interest
members are requested to declare the
existence and nature of any disclosable
pecuniary interest and or other
interests not already on their register
of interests in any item on the agenda
and withdraw from the meeting at the
appropriate time are there any
[Music]
declarations we move move then to item
three minutes of the meeting held on the
31st of July just to advise you that
there will be an amendment under the
Declarations of Interest councilor row
um declared that he was a member of the
parish council you will see that on the
minutes it says streten it should read
sherland Parish
Council apart from that
Amendment any other
comments if not then can we have a
proposal that they are
approved yeah I'll move that thank you
and the second thank you Council Barry
all those in
favor anyone
against any
abstentions and that's carried so item
four um Chairman's
announcements well many of you will have
watched the FIFA Women's World Cup in
July of this year you will know that the
defender Millie brigh was a former pupil
of kilar Junior school and eckington
school after watching a friend play for
killer Mar dynamos Millie decided to
join the
team the rest is
history her journey from Northeast
darbishire to 73 appearances for England
is an amazing one the team made us all
feel very
proud I'm sure you will join me in
congratulating them but particularly
Northeast darish Millie
bright in August Jean and I attended the
Kao
Gala it is wonderful to see the event
resurrected after many years in OB
bance the attendance was tremendous and
there was a real Community
atmosphere Penny cage and Sam Sherlock
are to be congratulated on their hard
work to facilitate the gala it was
worthwhile we had the privilege of
representing the authority at a Civic
ceremony at Chesterfield burough Council
to award the positions of honory
Alderman and older woman on three former
counselors it is special to see members
of local government recognizing
dedication to the community of their
peers one of the older men is now a
Northeast darbishire
resident thank you to those who
supported the Dawn Rose Boat pull along
the stretch of canal Chesterfield
canal and that includes my special
thanks to councelor Barker and councelor
Barry the work of the Canal Trust is
supported by our
Council it was great to see firsthand
all that the volunteers are
achieving even if I was harnessed with
councelor Elliott for some of the
time my thank thanks to councilor Elliot
for his usual camaraderie that
afternoon the Ireland Cy Chesterfield
Brass Band concert was a huge
success it is pleasing to know that the
band is doing so well and representing
our mining Heritage in such a positive
way if you haven't yet purchased tickets
for this week's curry lunin in
conjunction with the Asian Community
Association please see Joe Hayden
it promises to be another brilliant
occasion thank
you item five then leader of the
council's announcements over to you
please councelor Barker right am I on
thank you chair yeah that's great uh and
uh I hope everybody had a enjoyable uh
August or the uh the recess uh and since
coming back I've been uh been quite busy
like Martin just said first thing I did
will pull a barge along Chesterfield
Canal thanks for that that an
experience uh I've had several fault
opportunities uh the first one being
down clay Lane and handing over the keys
to Seven affordable homes to local uh
people uh I would also given a spade to
break the soil on uh W ley's Avenue
eventually I couldn't find key for it
mind you I could start it the the speed
I don't know what how you
welome that were a joke
that it very poor well but both of these
are start to demonstrate our commitment
to increase the number
of
affable in the district both Council Al
himself were invited to sh Park to the
launch of the CH active and that's
definitely coming on the swimming pool's
been dug and I think last week it got
filled up with a rain uh this morning I
did some filming in D mall with the
Sustainable Building Solutions that were
doing the uh external wall
insulation uh and obviously all the the
benefits that brings to to our tenants
as you've seen I did my last leaders
briefing from Ash over Rock uh which
after a couple of technical issues out
to illustrate where a great part of the
country that we live in in that update I
mentioned the prosecution of someone for
fly tipping in hfield I also mentioned
the two closure orders in uh in West
andley and Ridgeway and I fa to say Lee
I think it was a very complex operation
between the police and our officers and
I would like to put on record my thanks
to all those involved uh and I'm pleased
you didn't T me to get involved with
regards the council plan myself and
other portfolio holders have been
involved in the service planning phase
these are shaping up nicely and on track
to be completed by October we're also
busy developing the people Asset
Management housing and engagement
strategies and just to finish given the
recent announcment from some neighboring
authorities I can reassure the council
that while still having to make savings
this council is fiscally sound however
we do still need to monitor what's
happening elsewhere as this may affect
delivery of some of the projects that
we're involved in in Northeast arish so
uh we're keeping an eye on it
Al for you make it more money that's it
thank
you thank you Council Barker so item six
is public participation but there have
been no public questions so we're going
to move straight to item seven which are
the appointments to committees so we're
going to uh ask the monitoring officer
to explain the changes
please thank you chair this report
recommends changes to the membership of
planning committee and business scrutiny
Committee in accordance with the labor
group's rules and in accordance with the
proportionality rules the particular
changes are in the recommendations thank
you
chair you are there any comments or
questions not then I'm going to ask for
a proposer yeah I'll move those thank
you and the second thank you Council
Barry all those in
favor anyone against any
abstentions that is
carried so item eight then the formation
of a local plan review working
group
so you Council
[Music]
Pickering thank you chair um yeah this
is um to propose uh the establishment of
a local plan review working group um as
I said at the last meeting it's a long
overdue um for this piece of work to
take place um and and I did say at the
last meeting that we were going to start
it in the Autumn well we're just about
at the Autumn now so um you know we want
to Kickstart this and uh get it moving
forward um The Proposal is to recommend
to the council that a local plan uh
review working group be established um
at the meeting today and to recommend a
structure for the working group in terms
of membership and terms of reference and
you've got those at appendix a uh and to
consider the merits of the
recommendation members uh to the
structure um you've got the three uh
recommendations um there in front of you
um to approve the establishment of the
local plan review working group um
consisting the chairs and vice chairs of
the scrutiny committees the planning
committee chair and vice chair one
liberal Democrat group member and one
member from the Independent group um and
uh we will be uh I'll be moving shortly
a point appointments of those members
and that the review working group will
be chaired by myself or if I'm not
available the chair of the environment
um and place um
group um so you've got the paper there
in front of
you chair um if there are any questions
before I move the
recommendations and well if not I'll
move the rec just a minute just
um we just need a second if you're going
to move Council Pickering can can I a
second and and just uh defer me R to
speak if I need than you so we have got
questions so I'm going to hand over now
to councelor
Shipman um yeah yeah I mean I can vote
for this one thing I would say though is
it's it to have it just for the chairs
and vice chairs of each group seems a
bit bizarre because surely you want
people who are interested in shaping the
local planning reviewing it properly
rather than people who are just
appointed because of the position
elsewhere in the council so it might
have been worth just considering you
know maybe people from different
committees but that the groups
themselves could have chosen them I mean
we can choose ours clearly um but labor
and conservatives are not going to have
that privilege you're going to kind of
be stuck with whoever the chair and vice
chers are even if they're not that
interested at local plan you coun
cupit thank you chair um I find myself
in the unenviable position of agree with
councelor shitman um I've got
a you can frame it afterward um I've got
a few comments along those lines um
whilst I'm grateful this hasn't taken a
decade like last time I am concerned
firstly by the change from a pre the
previous Steering group that we had to
this which is a working group it's to me
it seems reading the terms of reference
it seems quite a dilution of of the um
of the group and the sort of powers that
they have and I fear that that change to
working group means there will be no
public record minute streaming of the
minute of the meetings though I hope
there will be and would urge sort of
clarity and commitment on that from um
the
administration um because this is an
issue that is important to many
residents and most elected members and
so I hope these meetings are therefore
accessible to them and to all elected
members um which leads me on to the
second sort of key concern that I have
uh which is makeup of the group uh as
councelor Shipman's indicated it's at
best I think a random composition and at
worst if I was being politically cynical
a conscious one to try to exclude some
members whilst I can see the Optics of
presenting it as an inclusive working
group incorporating SC scrutiny I'm not
sure how you can get to a conclusion
that two conservative members when we
have 18 on the council representing
areas across the district is appropriate
when compared with other groups who have
a lot less members still getting a seat
on the working group now I don't I don't
object to that I think that's a positive
thing thing but I feel very strongly and
I think my group does that the future of
the local plan and planning in this
District should have more of a political
balance and therefore should be
officially proportioned and also that as
a conservative group we should be
allowed to choose which members sit on
that group have substitutes where we
choose Etc so I'm voting against this
paper in its current um form and i' sort
of urge the administration to
reconsidering it before uh moving and
forcing it through today because as a
final point I'll again remind you and
I'm sure I'll do this often of your
commitment to openness transparency and
collaboration and at the moment with
this paper that Rings a bit Hollow to me
so thanks chair thank you Council
Welton uh thank you chair I was
disappointed in this um I think when we
had the new Administration there was a
commitment to be fair inclusive and
transparent uh and I'd like to point out
the areas in which I think this is
disappointing and ask counselor B
Council Pickering to reconsider uh the
format that this is going to take place
first of all is it inclusive no it's not
inclusive because it's not politically
balanced if it was a committee rather
than a working group it would have to be
politically balanced it's not J
geographically balanced either um my own
Ward dronfield woodh house gossi Valley
there's no representation and yet we are
in the Forefront of the land that will
be looked at to take out of green
belt is it it transparent no it's not
transparent will the meetings be public
and recorded or will they move straight
in some form of
confidentiality will the working group
report to full Council no this is a very
important issue for all members it
reports to
cabinet
the three Northern towns of kilar
aington and dronfield I think we need an
inclusive policy and I really would ask
councelor Barker councelor picking
bearing in mind the remarks that were
made at the start of this Administration
to reconsider the format thank
you councilor
Dale thank you chair I won't lab the
point just to Echo the comments that
have already been made
um you know this is a vitally important
issue across across the piece across the
council I respect the fact that it's
been done on a cross party basis I think
that's the right thing to do it affects
all of us affects all of our residents
and I think it would be very helpful to
have as much resident involvement in the
local plan review or new local plan uh
moving forward as possible I think
that's a really positive thing but I
think it's got to be done on a
proportional basis I think you would
expect us to to request that I think
Council liot and Council kff would do an
excellent job but I think the way in
which they've been selected I think
that's taken a role away from the
conservative group it really ought to be
our uh Choice as a group who those
members should be and as I say there
ought to be more of them to reflect the
the political balance really and would
just agree with the points around
collaboration openness and transparency
I think the transparency point is really
important um you know not just for our
sake but for the whole council's sake
there's a reputational challenge here if
these these meetings aren't done in an
open way so would' ask for clarification
around whether they will be public
whether there will be minutes recorded
whether other members of the council can
attend uh as well and and hopefully
participate um so yes I think I would
agree with all the comments made so far
thank you CH thank you councelor
Foster thank you chair um I agree with
what most what's been said by uh well
all of what's been said by councelor
Welton and uh and my other colleagues
and including uh councel Shipman um
absolutely uh it's not appropriate for
the controlling group to pick the
opposition's representation at all and
if um if I was to ask just one thing one
single thing of our leader here of the
council leader uh Council Barker is that
you at least at the very minimum allow
political groups to pick their own
representation as a very minimum uh it's
not appropriate at all thank you chair
thank you councilor
Hancock thank you chair um this is too
low for me
uh yeah I'm actually going to Echo what
everybody said but given that we've
actually got a motion on the table I'm
going to move an amendment that we look
at forming the committee from political
balance and allowing every party to be
part of that and to appoint their own
membership um so uh I I'll put that
before Council and ask someone to second
that please I'll second that chair thank
you so what bit are you amending in
terms of
recommendations in terms of the
membership ship chair um that
uh yeah sorry I'm looking at 4.1 instead
of the thing so to to actually amend the
membership to allocate the 13 members
but that they should be done on
proportionality with each party
represented and allowing the parties to
pick their own
membership thanks so we're now going to
uh debate the uh suggested Amendment the
amendment so are there any comments or
questions about the amendment Council
Dale and Council foret thank you um just
to ask if I can make an amendment to the
amendment uh just agree with everything
that's been said and whether we could
just add on an additional
recommendation that uh invites that the
are recorded uh you know open for
attendance to the public unless there is
some other specific reason by which they
shouldn't um shouldn't be included in
that discussion so obviously allowing
for exempt an exempt section of the
minutes at the meeting but but for all
intents and purposes they are open and
they are recorded in the usual way
that's a long sentence
sorry you translate that for me I'm
happy to accept that as a right so
that's been accepted as a friendly
Amendment to the amendment so thank you
councilor Dale so we'll just paraphrase
that about openness to the public public
um yeah Mr sternberg's got that so we're
adding as well as proportionality and
allowing groups to choose members that
we're also um adding to that about
openness to members of the public to be
able to observe Council force
it thank you chair we're um we've dived
straight into amendments here quite
quickly um and I think probably need to
refer via the leadership and perhaps to
governance where and how it's come about
that this plan and the terms of
reference that it's come from as to why
this has been the output is in terms of
where the roles are being sourced from
so if we could have some advice before
we consider those amendments from the
leadership and govern governance I think
that would inform counselors a lot more
[Music]
clearly I'm going
to well there's a lot of penp pointing
um so um in terms of the actual um the
governance element to it I'm just going
to ask for awesome advice from Mr
Sternberg to see if there's anything
that um you could assist with but then
I'm going to turn to council Mar to to
comment uh thank you chair I can't
comment on the selection of the model
that is obviously for the political
leadership but just to confirm what
you're probably already aware of as a
working party it's not subject to
proportionality rules it doesn't have to
be streamed or open to the public they
can choose to have minutes they're
working group can choose to have minutes
notes whatever of their meetings which
can be distributed thank you that's
helpful thank you Council
Barker yeah thank thanks yeah
um I thought this were would be
straightforward I thought out of the
four options we we'd been as
inclusive after all the four I mean
there one of options where the cabinet
basically could have done it uh we did
take advice I don't know if David wants
to explain uh the background down to to
some of these options I don't want to
put you on the spot David but I
am well you don't have permission of the
chair to do that oh sorry so if you
could continue Council Barker just
explaining and answering the points that
have been raised then yeah yeah well in
that case then uh I'm happy to to to not
support the
recommendations uh as you say we through
governance we can look at the uh uh
minting of the meetings and and and all
that uh but thing and it it lays out the
benefits of of this option in the paper
uh that it is uh it does have a broad
range of members uh all the political
groups are
involved uh it's it's got a strong
alignment with the scrutiny process
because obviously the chairs and vice
chairs will be on that uh every scrutiny
committee will be there so we can all
we're all knowing what's what's coming
off uh what's coming out of that working
group uh and I
think I I'm happy to stick with what
we're proposing in front of us so I
can't I'm I won't be supporting the uh
the Amendments as as uh as explained and
I don't know if if if if you want to
allow David I I am going to now Council
I just needed you to complete what you
were saying because Council forc asked
for a a leadership VI and you've now
provided that yeah and I'm now going to
ask the the director to to come in and
give us some assistance please thank you
chair um so from from an officer
perspective um we considered that there
was Merit in um aligning the the
membership of the working group to the
scrutiny committees simply from the
starting point that obviously this is a
um you know an exercise of strategic
importance and therefore how is the
business of the council run and and the
link to the scrutiny committees was was
considered to be you know following that
logic um and then in recognition of the
the overall aspiration of the the
leadership in terms of um
inclusivity that's where the uh the
additional items of both planning
committee
representation and also having one
independent and one liberal Democrat
member came so that that's the the logic
chair thank you does that answer your
question Council
foret no no to to reply thank
you um so back to my list of we've got
Council Foster then Council
Shipman thank you chair uh thank you for
for that answer and uh uh those details
uh councelor Barker uh could I ask
because um I know you've spoken once
I've got that but it's there's there's a
fair few things in that Amendment could
ask that either if not yourself but your
your Deputy leader if they're all to
speak uh on this amendment give us an
idea on what would be acceptable because
you've already intim there that you may
be that you'd be willing to uh have
minutes rather than the notes so the
minutes which I think is is is a massive
step forward that was one of one of my
main issues with the last local plan
Steering group um uh under prior uh
labor Administration so you've already
uh said there that you would be happy
with the minutes would you be willing to
go as far as that we're allowed to
choose our own if not uh so we can't
choose our own I'm getting
a so in other words you're dictating
which ones you want right okay
I think that's really poor when it comes
to if I'm honest that's really poor when
it comes to openness and collaboration
that you're willing to that you're
choosing out of us which ones you want
on your committee that's that's as bad
as you get but thank you chair coun
[Music]
Shipman thank you chair um yeah I'm
quite disappointed actually with
councilor Barker's reaction to that at
least the very least the groups choos in
who they want and you basically admitted
that you want to CH pick and choose out
of the groups who that is apart from
terms of Independence apparently which
we can choose our own it seems so thank
you for that no you can't have you read
the paper yeah it doesn't it doesn't say
doesn't name one can we go through the
chair but I think what you'll find is
that uh I don't think you can choose
either oh okay we back to that in a
moment we need to have clarification
come back I just just on the point of of
aligning it with the scrutiny
committees I want the leadership to
understand that the scrutiny chairs and
V chairs do not speak for those
committees and therefore they are not
voicing their their opinions based on
the committee that they sit on they are
merely a chair of that committee not a
voice for it um but yeah I Echo what
councelor Foster said in that I think
it's really poor um the way that this
has been set up actually now it more has
come to light during this debate um and
yeah hopefully the amendment goes
through because I think it's needed
thank you Council
cupit thank thank you chair just just a
couple of um further points on on the
amendment and and I think primarily on
Council Barker's comments I guess two
two further queries from me we're sort
of discussing as if the four options in
the paper are that's it there's no
ability to change those there are other
options indeed there was the local plan
Steering group previously that was uh
politically balanced so I I don't
understand so I'm guess I'm quering for
the the chamber here today why we've
moved away from that and why those four
options have been presented as the the
only firm for when they're all a little
bit inadequate and I sort of Drew that
from from councelor Barker's comments
that he sort of accepted that they
weren't perfect we change them um and
then as a second point in relation to
the scrutiny chairs I I do take the
point that you were trying to choose the
widest sort of membership but there's a
concern with that for me that it's sort
of like the administration's marking its
own homework because you've got the the
sort of a few of the cabinet members the
relevant cabinet members and the
scrutiny chairs you've got a majority
which is which is acceptable but it sort
of feels like you're marking your own
homework whereas a broader proportion of
members chosen by each party would have
been a more acceptable uh sort of form
and more inclusive I think so just those
two further comments from me thanks
chair Council
Welton yes just in favor of the
amendments to move to a committee
process for the reasons which I've
outlined others have as well you're
turning scrutiny into something that
it's not scrutiny is there to scrutinize
decisions or work that have been made
within the council and other bodies of
interest and it's not there to be the
new steering committee so why don't we
just change the name of all the scrutiny
and turn it into oh it's now the
scrutiny and steering committees so
again councelor barrad in the context of
you know you said it many times about
being open transparent Fair I'd ask you
to reconsider this enter into some very
probably quite quick talks with the
group leaders and I'm sure that a
solution can be reached that would
accommodate all members interests thank
you any other comments or questions on
the
amendment
all yeah just one comment um as an
independent um maybe and I think I will
support the amendment but it's just the
um the nature of of the work that this
body will do and the contentious
potential contentious nature of that
body and the wisdom of um showing that
political balance um in terms of public
P
perception um just that comment thank
you any any
more not then we're going to vote on the
amendment I'm going to come back to
council Hancock has the proposed see if
there's any other comments you want to
make nothing else CH I think everyone
said everything oh certainly one half of
this room has said everything that I
think needs to be said Thank you so
coming to the amendment then so as you
know the the amendment is about
proportionality and uh allowing groups
to choose their own Representatives on
that working group and about public
openness as well check can we ask for a
recorded
vote so far it's just
you yes we we got
enough so we've got enough members now
we're calling for a recorded votes I'm
going to hand over to Mr Sternberg to do
the roll call we are voting on the
amendment the
amendment you Mr
sber thank you chair I'll read your
names in order please say whether you're
voting for against or abstaining in
relation to the
amendment and you'll forgive me I
haven't got everybody marked who's not
here councelor Baker for councelor
Barker against councilor Barry councilor
bter councilor
Beach councilor
Burkin here Council
cheum councilor
CLE councilor
cluf counc Cooper councilor
cornall councilor cupit councilor Dale
four Council
Elliot Council em Council em isn't here
Council forces for
it um councelor
Fletcher councelor
forer councelor
G councelor gillet counc Hancock for
Council
harthorn against councilor
Higgin
[Music]
councelor Jeff moley
yes councelor
Peterson Council Pickering
against Council Reed is
not Council
Reed Council
row Council Rouse
councilor
Shipman four councelor
Skinner councilor Caroline Smith
councelor Christine Smith again
councelor Mick Smith against councilor
Spooner councelor
Stone Council
Tate not here Council ther four Council
Welton Council weather all or Council
windley
next
so the results are 17 votes in favor 25
against and no abstentions the amendment
is
lost so we return now to uh the
substantive discussion about the
recommendations as
written are there any other comments or
questions about
those councelor Barker then your you
read you second to me you did uh yeah
obviously we're sticking with the The
Proposal there uh I think just to make
it clear within that that uh for the in
the recommendation St in the the council
appoints a liberal Democrat and
independent members to serve on that
local plan review so
uh I'm I'll second those things there uh
we have listened to what's been said uh
but we are sticking with that we need to
get on with this it's something that uh
as we keep getting getting reminded
about the the length of the last one
that we need to have a review of this uh
and and the sooner we make a start on
that the better and the idea is it's not
for the people on scrutiny to be
speakers for that scrutiny committee
it's there so you can feedback whatever
into that uh scrutiny committee and to
your group what's happening on that
working group
because I can see it's going it's going
to be tortous I think is it I can tell
that we're going to be playing politics
with this for the next four years but
it's got to be done and I think we're
all want to build the house right houses
in the right place and that's we've all
got an agenda on that we every one of us
and let's be honest with that it's not
an easy process but we've got to do it
so let's be mature about that and try
and get this this get this
through Council Pickering your right a
reply thank
you thank you chair yes I mean it's been
very interesting discussion I talked
about transparency and openness
in the last Administration I were on the
local plan working group along with
Council Barker so I don't know if that's
proportionate or not there were two of
us and I think in the whole of the four
years it met twice I think it might have
only been once but I think it met twice
um and certainly not in the last 18
months when this piece of work could
have been done so I think what we're
proposing and where I'm going to move in
a minute is uh far superior to what
we've had in the last Administration and
hopefully we can be constructive and
work together to produce something that
will benefit the people of Northeast
arish and not individual Party politics
um so with that chair I'm going to move
the recommendations um as they are one
two and three and under two I'm going to
move um to represent The Independents
councelor Cooper and to represent the
liberal Democrats councel
hanock so um Council you've already
seconded it so we we've had cart and
horse situation but we'll take that as
proposed and seconded thank you chair so
uh I'll second that we need a third
we've got a third right that's it
we we now uh back to as I say
substantive recommendations which you've
heard outlined and the the named
individuals so we're going to recorded
vote so back to you Mr Sternberg thank
you chair as before I read your name
please tell me if you're voting for
against or abstaining councelor
Baker councilor Barker for councelor
Barry councelor Baxter councilor Beach
councelor cheum councilor
CLE councilor cluf councilor
Cooper councilor
Cornwall counc cupit against Council
Dale Council Elliot Council foret
Council
Fletcher Council
Foster Council
gar g apologies apologies councelor
gillet councelor Hancock against
councelor harson for counc hiin
councelor Pam
Jones councelor William Jones councelor
Kerry councelor Carol Lacy four
councelor Tony lafy four councilor
liot councilor moley
four councelor Peterson four Council
Pickering four Council Rouse four
councelor
Shipman okay councelor
Skinner councelor Caroline Smith
councelor Christine Smith Council Mick
Smith for Council Spooner against
councilor Stone
councilor facker
against Council Welton Council
weatherall Council windley
yes
this
right so results are 24 votes in favor
15 against and one
abstention so that is
carried so now moving to item nine
questions from Members asked under
procedure rule number
9.2 so it's question a from councelor
Jones to councelor Pickering councel
Jones will the portfolio holder confirm
if the new Administration will increase
fines for
fly tipping and littering to the new
National maximum amount allowable as
recently increased by government and if
so when Council
pick
thank you um thanks very much for your
question um councelor Jones it is uh
quite important and a serious issue for
Northeast darbishire
um you know we do experience quite a bit
to that what we need to remember is that
issuing a fixed penalty notice is an
alternative to
prosecution and if that offender doesn't
pay the fixed penalty notice we must be
prepared to prosecute them for the
original
offense um and in that case whatever the
fines are issued by that Court we don't
receive that resulting money we get
nothing from that although we have to go
to the expense of
Prosecuting we know that um when the uh
last increases were made in
2122 uh from 80 to
150 uh this is for littering um the
actual payments of those dropped by 20%
we were getting 100% payments they drop
down to 80% so uh people were avoiding
that new increase which obviously then
meant that we had to prosecute for
that um and we need to be in mind that
you know fines need to be proportionate
and we are in a cost of living crisis we
want people to be able to pay that
penalty as a
deterrent um rather than just
criminalizing
people um in Flight tipping cases which
we've had quite a lot of and um some of
it quite Dreadful stuff um we don't give
a fixed penalty for that where it's
significant uh waste involvement then we
do go to prosecution for that um and uh
where those offenses are considered more
significant um and that can result in an
unlimited fine or up to five years
imprisonment um so the existing penalty
of £400 is currently considered to be
appropriate for case where fixed penalty
noises are currently issued um and we
prefer to retain that current balance
between fixed penalty notices and
prosecution it is constantly under
reviewed and over the next 12 months we
will keep uh a close eye on that um so
that we're informed about the cases
where we need to look at increasing that
or not um but at this moment in time
there's no plan to increase the fixed
penalty notices thank you supplementary
question Council
Jones Thank You counc P I think the
issue here is that this is a very
important matter and the council have
invested in CCTV cameras so is it the
intention to enable prosecution to be
more positive to set in place a strategy
utilizing the CCTV cameras for for
targeted surveillance at flight tipping
hot tip hotspots to identif ify
offending tippers and
vehicles and what what other measures
are we going to set in place it is an
important issue I appreciate the cost of
living issues but there are big
organizations involved in fly tipping
and money is then not a problem thank
you Council pick you want to answer
those two questions one sneaked in I
will I will CH I'll try and do them both
I mean um yes uh councelor Jones it is
it is quite difficult there are um some
places where it's regularly done and
they're monitored um but the people that
are doing that the larger organizations
are quite crafty about it and they're
finding places where we've not got uh
cameras or monitoring um our
environmental um Health Services do a
thorough job in investigating wherever
they can um you have seen councilor
Barker referred to in his comments
earlier on that in West andley and
Ridgeway there was a a a significant
operation um that our staff and they
need to be praised for that put
themselves forward in light to potential
danger there's a danger to that these
criminal elements are violent at times
it takes a guts it takes guts to do that
and I'd like to now really thank our uh
Workforce for the dedication and the
effort that they put into that it's
Sterling work um there's been a case um
sherland or pills way I think it was
where uh we investigated or the
environmental team investigated that and
where they can find evidence for those
fly tippers and they do search
thoroughly they will be prosecuted but
people become more crafty the evidence
is not easy to be found and people that
do see it won't come forward and offer
themselves up and I can quite understand
why it's very dangerous but our
environmental service as this Authority
is committed to wherever it can seeking
out and Prosecuting significant ific fly
tipping and we will give fixed penalty
notices for lesser offenses but
significantly they do damage our
environment thank you thank you question
B then Council cupit your question to
council Pickering please thank you chair
um Can Council Pickering confirm whether
you'll be pursuing a local plan review
or a new local plan what the time frame
for work on this is and importantly what
the plans for public consultation with
any affected communities will be I think
that's a more apt question in given
earliest debate thank you counc
Pickering to
reply thank you thank you councelor kit
for that well we've just had quite
significant discussion about the local
plan um and what that's going to be um
whether it's a review or whether it's a
new local plan um will be the work of
that working group its first stage will
be um uh for the agenda for that is to
undertake um to scope the review to see
what needs to be done there is potential
ually new legislation coming in from the
government um about planning we'll have
to take that into account um and
officers have already been uh doing some
review uh on the local plan to see
whether it's up to date um or not see
where we go and we'll also be using a
planning advisory service toolkit um to
follow best practice um which will
advise us or inform us about whether
that's a review or a new local plan um
the of time that will take um will
depend on um on how the group works you
know the option that we've gone for in
terms of decision
making wasn't the easiest it's got 13
members on it um but I think that's the
best um the way to go because we do get
a view no matter what people think from
all political aspects of um this Council
you all have group meetings you can all
discuss you can put your points into it
um so we do expect it to take probably
longer than just cabinet City coming up
with something um because we want it to
be
inclusive um and so it might be it might
take four years it might it might be
sooner it depends how quick that on how
well that group can work together um and
there is in there uh plans obviously for
um uh wider public
consultation
than question
yes thank you chair um I note the the
use of councilor Pickering said we I
think four times and inclusive twice but
it won't be we because I won't be on it
f the debate so thank you very much for
that coun but to lead to my question um
I'd just ask for a yes or no answer in
terms of as an Administration are you
looking are you aiming to do a local
plan review or a new local plan given
the comments and information you have so
far thank you chair yes we're hoping to
do either the riew all the
plan thank you so uh question C then
councelor Dale to councelor Kerry yeah
thank you chair will the port portfolio
holder please confirm the financial cost
or provide an estimate if not yet
established of each of the new standing
commitments announced by the leader of
the council in his acceptance speech on
the 22nd of mayk you chair thank you
Council Kerry to
[Music]
reply thank you as a Council we approved
a budget for
2324 in January this year we inherited
that budget in May and intend to work
within that to deliver our services to
date we have incurred no additional
Revenue
expenditure but to do intend to address
commitments in the council plan in
relation to community safety and
sustainability during this budget cycle
these can be funded from within the
existing
budgets further we haven't incurred any
additional capital
expenditure but as you will recall from
the last meeting of the council we plan
to progress with the Regeneration scheme
at Stone Brom which will require future
consideration by this Council in due
course as part of the annual review of
the budget we will review delivery
commitments in the council plan and the
financial commitment required if any the
budget review is currently underway and
will be presented to the council for
consideration and approval in January
next year following robust review by The
Joint scrutiny
committee supplementary question Council
Dale thank you chair um one of the
aspects that was missed out with the
response was in relation to this Council
chamber it's already been alluded to
that might be some changes are thought
and Council Barker also alluded to uh
making it more professional I just
wondered if you could confirm how much
will be spent on the council chamber and
whether you think that's a sensible
decision given the financial climate at
the moment and what residents will think
about councilors investing in their own
Council chamber Al
K that's all been ordered and taken into
account um and you know I hear here the
PO calling the kettle black all the
other way around uh we wonder what H
what's going to happen in play cross if
if the county can't fulfill their perit
commitments to that scheme as
well yeah hopefully next it's not to you
Council bar but nice try moving on to
agenda item 10 to consider any motions
from Members under procedure rule number
10 uh the first one is motion eight from
Council
cupit thank you chair um I I'll deserve
most of the right to speak but just as a
few uh sort of intro comments um I
brought this forward for for two reasons
this motion uh hopefully quite
self-explanatory firstly I was pretty
disappointed by the answer to the
question my colleague councelor liot
raised on this issue last meeting and
most importantly because it's something
residents keep raising with me as far as
I was concerned the decision to extend
green bin collections was unanimously
agreed by everybody in this chamber at
the time last year on a cross party
basis and it was something weird the
previous cabinet were looking to
implement in May ready for this year so
the case added up for it in terms of
Weights of materials and demand for the
service or be it on a slightly reduced
monthly winter cycle and it also makes
sense in terms of keeping people in The
Habit in relation to recycling and
garden waste therefore residents members
and even many of the refuges collectors
themselves support this so I hope
Council can support it too thanks chair
thank you and Council Dale to Second
happy to Second and reserve my right to
speak here thank you so any comments
Council
Welton thank you chair again I was very
disappointed by this reversal of policy
two reasons first of all it was
something that I think was in two groups
political manifestos it was in the
conservative group Manifesto I believe
it in the liberal Democrat Manifesto as
well it reflect residents concerns
councils at the heart are about a bundle
of services and this was a very good way
of a small
incremental Improvement in a basic Sur
this and wasn't taken so again I go back
to the original remarks made by
councilor Barker about being inclusive
and open this again is not inclusive it
also is something that like comes up in
my casework often that's about trees and
verges not being cuted but also about
the bin collection and it was seen by
residents in my own Ward as a major a
major gesture everybody realized about
constraints on budgets and everything
but it was seen as a major step forward
so I was very disappointed in this thank
you
Co thank you chair um I'm going to have
my voice um because it was a cross party
announcement in the first place it was
myself as on the liberal Democrats and
Charlotte who actually put this forward
to council we did it because of the
changing environment the fact that the
growing season is far longer than it
ever used to be it made perfect sense it
was it was all there I think even the
labor group who were here at the time
fully backed it so there's absolutely no
logical reason as to why why there's a
change Direction now it's needed by it's
not just wanted it is needed by people
because of the extra Surplus ways
through the year um the we saying we
don't need it is actually turning our
back on climate change and the impacts
it's having on people so uh obviously
I'm going to fully support this motion
Council bker yeah thank you chair to be
honest I'm a bit confused with this for
two or three reasons uh one firstly I
thought we answered the question at the
last meeting in uh from Council liot
about running around with empty bins uh
Bin lores that that use a lot of fuel
that's going to create all the cab and
stuff and I I just don't see why you
brought it again but secondly and I keep
I've read it loads of times the motion
that we that we agreed in November and I
I agree that we all agreed to it but I'm
sure it says the council will extend the
garden waste period And I can't see
anywhere where it says we'll collect it
throughout the winter period and it
don't say that it just says extend and
we are extending it for three weeks this
year which is exactly what we agreed at
that meeting so I don't see what what
that is and and finally this is a
proposal that in my head it's uncosted
and unfunded it's a financial commitment
that that you know he could lead to
bankruptcy and and I know you might do
that in other
councils you you know that that's
something you want to do you can do but
we don't want to do that we want
everything to be proper costed and
funded and as you know if if this is
like a change of policy what you
recommending here which you has to go
through scrutiny it has to be be proper
costed and then it'll have to come back
to cabinet for approval and you you're
trying to show sake it that uh so again
we've answered the question it's not an
issue so I don't see and we'll vote
against it thank you
any other comments Council Shipman thank
you chair um just want to talk about the
the financial aspect because on one hand
we've heard one member of the labor
group saying that the budget was agreed
in May so therefore the motion that was
agreed in November would have would have
been budgeted for in May and therefore
there is no extra Financial commitment
because that was budgeted for in May
after that motion was passed so
therefore this is a political decision
by labor not to extend it further into
autumnn
um and winter when that's already been
budgeted for and therefore I don't know
why you're trying to throw it back this
way because that's something that we all
agreed back in November hand has been
budgeted for in May's budget so
therefore it's it's just really bizarre
to me that you're now doing a uturn now
you're in power when we could be
continuing with this what was a unil a
consensus across all parties to deliver
this for our residents that that do want
it and need it and it's not just an
environmental um aspect in terms of
green BS it's a practical one because
what do you think happens with all the
Hedge cuttings in Autumn when there's no
one to come and collect it it ends up on
a fire so so it's all well and good
saying that the trucks going around the
district but people will be burning
waste instead of actually put it into a
compost pin which actually that was
another part of the motion in November
which was encouraging people to compost
the waste as well and I haven't seen any
action of that happening since last
November so perhaps that's something
else that the labor group need to look
at as well as a policy and continue that
motion any other
comments counc
Pickering thank you chair there um it
sounds as if councelor Shipman wants to
be as proplate as the conservatives do
in spending other people's money um they
proved that they're not capable of doing
it in another Council chamber um I
suppose we ought to be thankful that
Council Shipman's never had that
opportunity
um it was agreed that we would extend
this Council would extend that green B
uh uh Bin waste collection and we've
done that by three weeks there's an
extra two weeks uh this side of
Christmas and there's a week after
Christmas um if we extended it to cover
the whole period based on information
from neighboring authorities it's likely
to lead to an increase of just 2.5% of
recycling um or over what we usually
collect and the extra cost for that
extra period that they're talking about
over what we've proposed would be an
additional £82,000
they' perhaps like to tell the residents
of Northeast Arisha where that's coming
from when we're talking about really an
insignificant amount of waste collection
that could be composted saved until the
green bean starts or we've got two
excellent uh waste recycling sites that
are open apart from Christmas day all
all year where people can take ways to
so there's plenty of provision it's not
just us that's leaving people stranded
so there's that great cost and we' be
relyant on up to nine agency staff every
second fortnite which is not really
feasible to do that so when you look at
the logistics of currently where we are
and what we'd have to put in place it's
not something we can do overnight or on
the turn of a Sixpence it's something
that needs to be planned for we will
continually keep it under review uh and
as we've said
you know we're the only Authority that's
actually increased that after that
motion in November nothing had been done
the previous four years we're actually
taking some action now to extend it by
three
weeks Council Dale you wishing to reply
as a second thank you chair we're
hearing uh a lot of deflecting from the
labor benches at the moment about the
county council's problem I think at the
end of the day we are at Northeast arer
District let's focus on the district
council and the reality is you inherited
a very healthy budget from the last
conservative Administration it was
budgeted for and as far as the cost I
think and Council cupit will confirm on
this we did plan to implement it the
this additional cost uh was not
significant uh I think in terms of the
last motion that we approved in November
uh it may not be there in the exact
wording of the minute but I think
everyone in that meeting knew exactly
what we were talking about a significant
extension we actually weren't talking
about all throughout the winter we did
we did accept there ought to be a short
period of stay of execution whatever you
want to call it but a much more
significant extension into the winter
than we Curr currently have to get a a
pulser three weeks is a bit of an insult
I think to all the residents who who
supported that and really wanted to see
it happen and I think Council Pickering
tur turning it into a bit of a political
attack at the last meeting is really
disappointing I think ultimately labor
voted for that motion back in November I
think they knew what they were voting
for so the reality is kenler pickering's
attacking his own policy effectively and
I think the really important thing is
that the staff were up for it as well
you know what K keep it in I spent a lot
of time down at the Depot a lot of time
talking to Frontline staff and a lot of
them said that during the winter months
particularly the black uh Bin
collections um they felt that you know
that that time away from Green bins was
a bit a bit of a wasted opportunity they
really they were really up for it so I
just think it's really disappointing
that we're not um progressing with this
it would have made sense it would have
been had strong public support it would
have improved recycling rates I don't
think the cost would have been anywhere
near as significant as has been claimed
uh and yeah so disappointed really chair
thank
you so to respond counter cupit thank
you chair um just a couple of points
here in terms of the debate share
councilor Dale's disappointment I think
councelor pick it's quite sort of
interesting of you to comment that we
had four years to do it sadly we didn't
because of the the national
circumstances in terms of a pmic but
also due to the you know one of our main
contractors going into Administration
and that was a contractor that the
previous labor administration had signed
which which is what uh delayed sort of
extending on that front um I really I'm
really concerned by the scare mongering
on the budget and on Clay Cross that
Council varus just mentioned that's you
know that's completely inappropriate and
it's completely inappropriate to the
residents of playay cross and everything
else and I'll be interested to say given
that you've just said councelor
Pickering that you believe that the
green bin extension
through the winter would cost 82,000
I'll be really interested to see how
much the new Council chamber will cost
and I hope the figures don't match um
because I'll be very upset by that and
I'm sure residents would be likewise um
in terms of the the previous motion I
think again you know there's clearly
different Recollections in the chamber
but as councelor Hancock said at the
time I recall saying that we wanted to
extend it through the winter and it
would probably be on a monthly basis as
a trial so whilst it may not have been
in the wording it was certainly in the
debate that we all signed up to at the
time the councilors that were there on a
cross-party basis and just as a final
point I found councilor Pickin comments
in particular quite contradictory in
terms of the additional costs and you
know raising concerns about climate
change but then suggesting that people
drive their waste to a household uh
recycling center so he wants everybody
instead to get in the car and drive to
the local tip um and then also saying
that uh you'd have to put on Extra
Agency staff so I presume does that mean
we're not having agency staff during the
year or now or or anything else again
very contradictory in terms of it so I
would appreciate it sounds like you're
not going to support this motion so it
may fall but if it does I would ask you
to go and review and think very
carefully on introducing this proposal
to Residents that we all signed up to
thank you
chair so we we come to the voting on the
motion then so all those in
favor
all those
against any
abstentions thank you the motion is
lost move to motion B proposed by
councilor
Hancock uh thank you chair I've actually
just spotted a typo in this are you
happy to accept the motion with where
the in paragraph two it should say is
not in as it should say is not limited
rather I think it doesn't negate it so
you're all right thank you yeah other
than that it really is
self-explanatory um it is a case people
are suffering and they're suffering
because of um as we've said previously
on on other parts of the debates people
are suffering from a cost of living um
living um crisis as a council obviously
we can't do an awful lot here but we can
try and Lobby to help them so that is
really what the uh the motion is asking
for obviously the way that our our
district is divid up it it does fall
into two parliamentary constituencies
which is why we've got there so uh I I
move it to to council and hopefully
we'll get support on this so that we can
uh we can carry it through I'll second
that chair reserve my right to speak
thank you beat me to it Council Shipman
so uh so we're commenting on this debate
now so over to council Barker first yeah
thank you J uh well I've got some
sympathy with it and know people that do
pay this uh this this Levy or whatever
it's called Uh uh it's uh it's my
understanding and I've had advice on
this that the leveling up and
regeneration bill that's that's coming
through Parliament I think is a it's got
a new infrastructure Levy within it but
this will be a charge that will be
compulsory set locally and based on on
the development value and the
implications of these changes are
complex I think uh and to be honest not
clear about how all that or Li when when
it's all been passed uh so in my head
this motion preempts these changes and I
think we should it's a bit previous to
agree this Motion in front of us so
while I've got some symy with its
intention uh I don't think we can agree
at this point in time thank
you any other comments Council Dale
sorry chair it's more a matter of
clarification in relation to my
interests um I'm director of Northwood
and I believe Northwood is setting up uh
a similar or is in the process setting
up a similar management company to look
after the open space so am I a question
to Sarah really am I better not speaking
on this or abstaining
or um whilst the usual advice is in
these situations when I haven't had a
chance to think about it play safe you
might want to take into account that
that situation will be coming to an end
in the near future okay
so are you declaring or not I'll declare
the interest yeah okay
thank any other comment Council cupit
don't tell me you're abstaining as
well no thanks chair I I just um sort of
playing on um what council Barker said
my my thoughts on this motion and and
our groups were were very similar in
terms of there are National changes
coming through recognizing that there
are issues and I agree you know I've had
similar issues in in my uh Warden
division with um section 106s and with
management fees but because of those
government legislation changes that are
coming through my sort of suggestion to
to councelor hanot would be whether this
would be something that it would be
better for scrutiny to have a look at
and whether rather than just abolishing
uh management fees you know in total and
putting it onto section 106 as which we
know section 106s aren't always perfect
in terms of play areas Etc that actually
it could be a good scrutiny um topic so
that would be something we would support
but we
wouldn't not sure it fully sort of looks
at all the issues thanks chair you any
other comments or
questions to come back to council
shipment oh all just in time Council
Baker Council Baker and then I'll come
to you Council
Shipman thank you chair yes we discussed
this quite a lot at our group and of
course there are many of these around
the country agreements and and uh it's
something that when setting planning
permissions conditions perhaps councils
could uh be a little bit more thoughtful
of the of the uh costs and things going
down the line excuse me so if if quite
so much area want setting aside for
example down at the Avenue for parks and
green spaces there is a cost to maintain
it thank
you Council Shipman is in there thank
thank you chair um yeah just from
councelor Barker's point I mean waiting
until the horse has bolted before you
have a comment on something it's
probably not the wisest way at
approaching things you i' rather the
council make a decision whether it's one
way or the other and then put that
decision and Lobby it as best way we can
before the legislation's passed in
Parliament it seems bizarre to wait
until it's passed to then go oh actually
we disagree with that legislation surely
it's better to engage now start to try
and formulate or at least put our impact
on that legislation than wait until it's
forced upon us and then we've got to
kind of deal with whatever comes forward
it makes no sense us to wait and wait
and wait um but I do agree with um
councilor cupit that perhaps an
amendment might have been put forward if
that's what your opinion is on on it
that sends it around one of the
scrutinies to look at in more detail but
this is certainly an issue that's
affecting places like the Avenue as
Council Baker says um an UNL Grove in wi
wor these are real issues and and in
fact I'm quite worried that councelor um
um Dale has has said that the um
Northwood group's now looking at this
because this is a ccel
project and we're basically wanting to
pass this levy on to Residents that are
going to be living there to maintain
these green spaces um and and is it is
basically a tax on on new homeowners
because they are forever having to pay
this the money to to that's charged to
them will keep going up and I don't
think it's right I think we should
really be looking at the other model
which is the section 106 Arrangement so
the council takes a responsibility on
with the large sum of money that it can
bring in through 106 rather than keeping
that money with residents because a lot
of us are in situations where we're not
paying that management fee and I don't
think it's right to be putting that levy
on to the own home owners so I'll be
voting for this motion but equally um I
would personally accept an amendment to
um send it around one of the scrutinies
for them to look at in more detail thank
you J to suming up oh councel Hancock
you're right to reply thank you J yeah I
mean largely I agree with everything
Ross has said I I would have more than
happily accepted a friendly Amendment
had that been put forward um going back
to the northward one I'm not sure whose
comments I was more interested in Alex's
or Sarah's so I think a conversation
needs to be had somewhere along the
lines on a separate issue there um but
going back to to council Barker's
comment yeah absolutely we want to be
shaping this we don't want to be we
don't want to be saying oh we disagree
with it once the decision's already been
made if if we can influence that to
begin with that's by far the more
sensible thing so I genuinely put an
appeal out to his group to reconsider
their position and and to support
it we're now voting on motion
B all those in favor raise your
hands all those
against
any
abstentions the motion is
lost so motion C then councilor schikman
over to you thank you chair um as as
somebody that seems to have been um
involved in a lot of these issues that
have cropped up with il legal
encampments in the district um I see the
managing managing director smirking
because he knows I've had many many many
conversations with him about this
issue it it it appears to me that things
are getting worse for this District in
terms of illegal encampments every week
I seem to see something in darbishire
times about one in darbishire as a whole
but more but more frequently there's a
lot that that end up in Northeast
arire the issue that I'm seeing from
speaking to serving officers serving
sergeants different partners and
organizations that are having to deal
with these is that the police I going to
say reluctant but are refusing to do
what they have the powers to do and that
is just a fact and we've got the um
illegal encampments task force which
I've always called a talking shop
because it it it's the activities it's
supposed to do it it just doesn't have
the teeth to do there all it becomes is
meets with a landowner the landowner
says I've done a b CDE e the council the
police all the partners go that's great
thank you very much we'll put a press
release out Pat ourselves on the back of
how much work we've all done together to
achieve an outcome and I know firstand
from the last one that was at the Avenue
Washland I had my phone was blowing up
one they arrived the um people the
illegal cam arrived about 8 7 or 8:00 my
phone was blowing up by 10 past day I
was on the phone to the Lando and say
here we go again they had issued the
legal papers or started the legal
process that night a day later this
illegal encampment task force had
met and put a pressure relase out saying
oh yeah we've agreed all this stuff with
the landowner and I knew that the work
had already been put in 12 hours before
so nothing has been achieved at that
illegal encampment task force and that's
why it basically is a talking shop
because it achieves nothing and I think
that we need to engage with the police
because this is a policy um situation at
the top top level of the police this is
not the officers they're doing a great
job and just working within the
framework that they've got but I think
we need to engage with the police and
find out why they're not using their
existing section 61 Powers um and try
and get them to do more because without
that we're just leaving it to the land
owners to pick up them pieces and deal
with these situations so I propose this
motion chair and hopefully everyone can
support it thank you second for that
handu and I'll reserve my right to
speak so we're now on this debate
Council
Barker yeah thank you chair uh to be
honest I'm not not ever so sure where
you're coming with this because my
experience like two months ago uh some
Travelers turned up on a Wednesday at
North Wingfield there were a meeting on
Thursday and they' moved on by
Friday uh and I I don't think uh they
could have done more than that and I
also I think it's a matter of policy
really that as a council we don't attack
or criticize ize the operations or the
statutory bodies it's not our role to do
that we might not agree with everything
the police do but they've got their own
functions and their own uh way of
working and I think we should keep a to
that uh and on a matter I think
correctness I don't think I don't
believe anyone can prevent an illegal
encampment all we can do is deal deal
with when they present themselves I know
for a fact the the at Wingfield they
they cro a ball you know a proper big
lck and you there's no way we we could
have stopped that uh and and and credit
to previous administration I think this
task force that that that has been set
up with the PCC and uh and everybody
else I think it's brilliant uh because
we out that it were a week before we'd
actually done anything so I think fair
play I think it it's it's working really
well uh and so I won't be supporting
this motion thank you thank you Council
Dale yeah thank you chair I mean I think
the motion is a bit of an attempt to
simplify what I understand to be quite a
complex area uh probably for political
game to a degree I think um just on the
section 60 and section 61 I don't I
don't I don't profess to understand this
at all and I'm not particularly close to
it but my understanding is that they are
quite specific in terms of how they can
be used yeah I think having seen from
the task force from a distance again
would say I wasn't as closely involved
as as other members were my view was
that it was effective I think we had
really positive feedback from Partners
it was all about a partnership approach
bringing the right people together in a
room getting it getting the process
explained because quite often you know
Travelers will turn up at a site and the
landowner doesn't doesn't know where to
turn they don't have a clue what they're
doing and I think having that
information readily available the
partners there to support the police
there to be able to monitor things like
and social behavior or you know
undesirable behavior all those sorts of
things and and also you know on the
other side res tension all of those kind
of things I think it's important just to
bring Partners together I think it has
seen a reduction in terms of the time
the length of illegal encampments if I'm
honest I think when we when when it
before it was set up we were seeing them
lasting longer they do seem to move on
you know we can't stop them as councilor
Parker said but they do seem to move on
a lot quicker um and I don't think we're
seeing as many revisits as well it's
improved communication I think as I say
it's made the processes better um I
think just on that section 60 and sorry
62 and 61 and 62 I've written it down in
my notes 60 and 61 so apologies um I
think there's also a capacity issue here
and this is this is me surmising rather
than having any understanding of how the
police works but it takes a significant
um sort of Workforce in numbers to move
a travel encampment on I think if you're
pursuing those those methods and I think
we have to just ask ourselves do we want
the police to be focusing on chasing
Travelers round from one site to another
and constantly moving them on or do we
want them focusing on dealing with
really serious criminal issues you know
antisocial behavior all these other
things so I think there's a bit of a
where do you draw the line um kind of
aspect to this but just grateful to the
new Administration they are continuing
to participate in these because I think
that they are they're a good Innovation
I know that the other Council that I
think they've been trialed in feels much
the same way so hopefully they can be
spread out across the county so we won't
uh we won't be supporting the motion
either councelor adlington
Stringer thank you chair um I won't be
voting for this motion um for a number
of reasons um not because I don't
support land owners um or feel that we
have a a right and responsibility to
protect them but I I feel that the
overall strategy taken towards the
traveling Community is is wrong and some
of the language used in this motion I
don't think is particularly helpful uh
we refer to them as illegal encampments
they're a valid Community within our
country and pushing them from one place
to the next isn't solving anything um we
need a a better strategy not just in
Northeast arish but Nationwide in PR in
prevent in providing safe spaces um for
these communities to exist um we just
securitizing privatizing every piece of
land uh in the entire country and it's
it's giving people nowhere to go so I
won't be voting for this motion I think
we need a a different approach different
set of tactics and um again I'd just
like to highlight the use of language
around this and and recognizing these
are a distinct community that we we
should be supporting thank
you counc
Barry thank you
chair am
on it working all right I think for me
going back to the experience we've had
just recently at North Wingfield I have
to say the task force were absolutely
superb um both myself and councilor Mick
Smith were both both involved in in that
uh project and the way that the the
police the staff um be at do County
Council be Northeast do at Northeast
District worked together well and they
consulted and sports of The Travelers
and it came to a quick end and I think
we've got to remember that Travelers do
have rights as long with the rest of us
so I think going through this task force
and having that lays on and including
the people that would trying to move on
will'll do nothing but better
relationships between ourselves and
travelers so that's just the comment I
need to
make they left it nice and clean as well
by Council
Foster uh thank you chair uh I'd just
like to speak on um on the legislation
here the section 61 and section
62 uh I don't know how many people have
actually read this uh legislation it
looks what in the motion uh that these
Powers have have been given and it
almost implies that they've just been
given they're not section 6162 if you
read them they're easy to Google uh part
of the criminal justice public order
right 1994 so we've had them a long time
power to remove trespasses and they're
much more complicated as as councelor
Dale's um intimated earlier H when you
read them you can see that you have to
use threatening abusive words of
behavior or damage and six more vehicles
to be involved so it is more complic
ated and there are powers that aren't
always uh to be used and
there
this word I don't understand what you're
trying to do here you're show boting
again aren't
you
any other comments or
questions Council
CIT ju just briefly chair I think um
yeah just I think I'm probably the
member who's attended the most of these
as relevant portfolio holders since they
were set up uh previously and yeah I'd
agree with the the comments that have
been made that actually it's not just me
who said that they've worked it's the
private land owners who've got in touch
in the the parish councils who often
don't know what to what to do initially
because it's it's you know sometimes a
rare occurrence and you know the land
trust I remember on the Avenue quite
publicly uh stated that they were very
grateful and it also helped them provide
measures to deter sort of similar issues
going forwards in the future so it was
quite uh so we've had positive feedback
in in relation to that as well and also
in relation to the use of the powers
again the task force has led to that um
I think there was an instance at at
grassow uh when there was an encampment
and the police used their powers in that
instance because it was appropriate to
do so um so yeah just just to highlight
the positive feedback so unfortunately I
can't support this motion but just
noting councel Coral's comments I think
I'll put forward for a local plan Task
Force at the next
meeting I I think it's one of those
afternoons isn't
it so unless there's any other further
comments I'm going to come back to
council hanock as the second who's
reserved his right to speak and I'm sure
you will councilor hanock oh absolutely
abely thank you chair I'm going to
actually raise one very very important
Point here because this has been abused
by a lot of members here the wording in
this motion specifically says illegal
encampments because it doesn't refer to
Travelers there are not just Travelers
who use who who set up illegal
encampment and there are many Travelers
who use the sites that are already
provided for them so any any comments
that have been made are actually a slur
against that that shouldn't have been
made and I hope those members will
retract those coms because it's actually
appalling uh councilor Foster is
absolutely right about section 61 and
section 62 the key points is what can
what what the motion refers to are those
instances where it is applicable and
they are not being used um I'm kind of
surprised with some of councilor Cupid's
comments because lust were some of the
critics of um of the way that this has
worked so there's obviously different
messages coming out from different
people there um in terms of that um and
uh in terms of the reason why it's us
the has put this forward I think uh the
Langan grasm more wingerworth
round robin which was going on for quite
some time has been one of the ones where
it really hasn't worked terribly well
and that I think is um there's been a
lot of abuse a lot of intimidation
against local residents and that's why
rarely the these communities feel let
down by the police and uh that's why
it's on here it's got nothing to do with
the Snider remarks that have come from
uh councelor Foster who really shouldn't
be comen on a thing that makes reference
to his own wife because I would say
there's a declaration of interest there
anyway um but uh that's that's the
reason why it's here and I'll I'll hand
over to councel Shipman as a proposer
councelor Shipman your right to reply
thank thank you chair um I just want to
repeat the point that Council anot first
made because I think nowhere in this
motion does it make reference to
Travelers and I think it's people's own
interpretation of that and their own
bias towards a particular Community
that's made them think that that's what
it's about and ultimately that
encampments Can Happen by anybody the
legislation does is not just about a
particular community and nor would I
ever want that to be the case this is
about the police or at least us asking
the police why they've not used them
Powers so far and encouraging him to do
that if anyone's read any more into this
motion then that's up to you and you I
think you need to go and um have a word
with yourselves about that because
that's not what the intention of this is
about and Council corwells um inferring
that this is me grandstanding I would
like you to come and speak to the
residents on the Avenue and people
surrounding them areas and those through
around in lalain and you can come door
knocking with me and you can tell them
that you think I'm just making a
political point because I can tell you
now they are furious with the response
that the police have have had in those
particular areas and it's not
grandstanding to be coming to this
Council chamber trying to change policy
or at least lobbying for different
policy which is affecting our residents
that is what we are elected to do if you
want to sit there and do nothing on this
Council for four years fill your boots
but I will keep putting motions forward
to this Council and trying to change
things for the residents that I'm
elected to represent and I will be
supporting this motion even if others
would like this issue to
continue so we're now voting on motion C
so all those in favor please show your
hands all those
against
any
abstentions exensions the motion is
lost so motion D would you please
councelor
windley thank you
chair right we've all we've established
we've got a working
group and for the year local plan um and
I would ask that during this reflection
time of of this local plan and
meetings um to remember that we do need
homes for our younger Generations the
right types of houses in the right
places and we can't keep building on the
side of existing towns and Villages that
can't possibly have enough
infrastructure to sustain the
developments so I'm just asking that
this can be really thought out before
things are um actually agreed and set
into motion thank you do we have a
second thank
you Council
Barker yeah thanks I think we've mared
on this to death don't we today uh I
think we've talked about this motion but
but just to make it clear and I think
Steve Mar said this the the first thing
this working group will do is consider
the scope of the local plan and what it
reviews and the range of evidence
associated with it the allocation of any
additional land for development will
therefore be an evidence-led process and
cannot be prejudged at this stage so it
is a work of this working group that
that we will look at what what it needs
to do so we can't we're not supporting
that any other comments or questions C
Dale
thank you chair um I don't know what to
feel about this motion I'm a bit
conflicted to be honest I agree with
point one uh begin the process uh of
developing a local plan or local plan
review uh and begin that consultation
with local residents as early as
possible and I think that consultation
point is really important um because
it's not just consultation that we want
we want proper engagement with with
local residents so they feel fully part
of the process throughout I think you
know putting all the politics aside the
issues with the last local plan were
that you know it took a long time to
develop and then there were a set of
proposals that were put out to
consultation I think we need to work
with residents you know evidence
evidence Leed as you say but work with
residents around how they want to shape
their communities and a proper
meaningful way allow them to be part of
the process uh you so you know really
not just consult but really engage with
residents as part of that process so you
know broadly agree with that point the
second point I I don't really agree with
I think um
you know previously we've looked at
redeveloping Council owned land and
making you know creating more affordable
housing uh there is an argument around
developing some open open market sale
properties uh to make the whole approach
more viable to make it more affordable
you know if you if you build out
properties for sale you can build in
theory more affordable housing units
over a period of time I also think that
it makes for better communities I think
blind tenure is important I think pepper
potting social housing around a housing
estate is far better than having whole
areas of solely social housing um I
think it also depends how really we're
talking about social and affordable
housing whether we're including within
that the sort of new definition of
starter homes which are uh reduced price
uh open market sale properties
effectively um so yeah a bit conflicted
on that point I think we we do have a
duty to promote home ownership as well
obviously we need affordable housing we
need social housing but you know we need
home ownership as well on the final
Point not necessarily opposed in
principle to a new settlement uh but I
know that we've had disagreements before
with the livs around where that would be
located and I think the libdems uh
previous stated policy would it be it
would be on the North or west of the
district and to my knowledge the North
and the west of the district is either
covered by uh green belt or Peak Park
where we don't have any planning
Authority uh anyway so it's effectively
on the Green Belt which I couldn't
couldn't support so not necessarily
disagreement in in principle but
certainly can't agree with uh agree with
the stated policy of the D so tricky one
this motion for me thank you chair thank
you Council weather
all thank you chair thank you chair yeah
my point was um similar to councelor
Dale's on resolution two um I I was
seeking a clarification actually are you
saying only develop on counil loans land
social and affordable housing projects
what I think think I would prefer to see
is a mixed economy approach rather than
um you know every every social
affordable housing um unit being in the
same sort of area so I was seeking some
clarification on that whether that was
the
intention I'm sure you can clarify and
summing up um are there any other
comments or questions Council cupit
thank you chair um I Echo what councelor
Dales said in terms of my views on this
motion but just to to sort of B and the
reason why I don't feel that I can
support it is it's it's in relation to
the resolution and for it to go to the
relevant scrutiny committees in cabinet
and I appreciate that's probably been
done because of the Constitution changes
but comes back to the point I W rehearse
it again about involving members and and
the public so that's that's one of the
reasons why I feel I can't support it as
well as everything Council Dale said
Thank You
chair any other
comments Council Sheepman then a second
you reserve your right to reply so over
to you yes yes thanks um just on the
social and afford affordable housing
Point like councelor Dale kind of
contradicted himself with the social
housing would be councel properties
affordable housing would be out on the
Open Market at reduced rate so so
especially in particular places like
your ward I'm sure affordable housing
would be absolutely welcome because
house prices in that area quite High um
and I would expect a lot of people in
their WS are having similar sort of
issues that house prices are
skyrocketing um and you know we need
affordable housing we can't just put
them on the open market when we're
talking about catel owned land at the
the prices that is currently being
fetched on the market because new um
firstand buyers will struggle to afford
most properties that are being built in
this District you look at the Avenue
you've got two bed houses that are going
for well over 200 Grand now who can
who in this room can AFF for that as the
first time home probably all in room I
would have thought it's just not
sustainable and that's why it's about
making use of canelone land so that we
can increase the council's social
housing stock and we can put hous onto
the open market and affordable rate for
our kids and their kids um so that's why
that Point's there and I think it does
answer councelor Dale's point and
hopefully C councelor weather's point
but on the why app point of the local
plan we need to get that process started
now and I take the point that councilor
Barker said about the working group
trying to figure out what its scope is
once it meets But ultimately surely we
need to be looking forward to the new
local plan as soon as possible so that
can start this consultation get the
communities to help um direct what that
local plan looks like and start that
engagement early my understanding from
what this paper we had earlier was
establishment of local plan review of
the existing local plan well that's not
what's on on the table here this is
about looking at starting the new local
plan get that consultation in early and
start planning ahead rather than just
rushing around at the 11th Hour pulling
bits of green belt on the side of killer
Marsh out out of the green belt itself
and building there or doing the same in
dronfield or doing the same in ashover
doing the same in North Wingfield we
need to be looking now at where those
houses are going to be built because
it's all you know we're going to have to
build these houses at some point we can
all just sit here and hopefully it's
some another council's problem in five
10 years time but that's not what a
Forward Thinking Council should be doing
we really should be looking at this now
and like I say this is just the start of
a process this is not agreeing we must
do this but this is the start of looking
at that um at the committee stage
hopefully get everyone's opinion into
that process thank you
chair councelor Wiley your opportunity
to respond thank you
chair yeah I mean it is about involving
residents I mean time and again you know
we've had residents who've got children
grown up wanting to live not that far
away from their existing family and
there's nowhere for them to go so
they've got to move out of area and I
totally agree with what council
Shipman's just said yeah we do need more
social housing and it does need pre-
looking at and pre-planning out thank
you thank you so we're now voting on
motion D to all those in favor please
show your
hands all those
against any
extensions
so the motion is
lost so item 11 chair's urgent business
the is no urgent business so can I thank
you very much for your attendance and
declare the meeting closed thank you
[Music]
chair